the fallout continues two days after the
president asked georgia's top election
official to
find him more votes all i want to do is
this
i just want to find uh
11 780 votes
which is one more that we have because
we won the state
this incident causing a rift in a
republican party that's already at odds
over plans to challenge the county of
electoral college votes in congress this
week
democrats have uniformly condemned the
one-hour phone call and are urging the
fbi to open a criminal investigation
while members of the president's party
gave some mixed reactions
i didn't hear anything in that tape that
the president has hasn't already said
for weeks now this call
was not a helpful
call congressional republicans also
split over plans by dozens of gop
lawmakers to object to wednesday's
counting of the votes
ohio senator rob portman is one of the
latest republicans to come out against
the plan
saying in a statement quote i cannot
support allowing congress to thwart the
will of the voters
president trump meantime lashed out at
those who refused to challenge the
results on twitter calling them
the surrender caucus